if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off explaining to
us why trump really won the election
again inspectors
every state
almost every approved this
is thrown away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out
probably wait he's saying there was a
dead person in the envelope
rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow i mean is
this a normal amount i don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here i'll be in the
lawsuit that comes out duty's melting
arizona is a chemical oh no sam cedar
very carefully strongly looking at it i
would say we're probably
i assume
she's working if she's working for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time
you should have had the time and that
you to go look for them
[Music]
that's your job
like it's my job to defend the president
michigan wisconsin is is he bleeding did
you see is he bleeding from his ear
what on earth was that folks needed
to find out
does that hair die is to look at the
lawsuits in order to do it it looks like
blood
been in the material oh my god it's
everywhere's ten
thousand at least
and we're getting he's gotta get off the
stage and there are other aspects of
this fraud on the morning of november
someone's gotta get him a napkin they
were gonna count
i've never seen anything like this
man what on earth it's getting onto his
shirt now she again and it was con any
jury would accept as they heard this
evidence
that somebody had this plan this isn't
insane maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup the city described that to
you oh my god it's all over his face
he's gonna need a towel dealing with
drill evidence i don't know guys it's
sounding like trump won isn't it based
on this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
here i am wow that was weird i was like
missing for a second there that was very
very strange but here i am i was blacked
out
what incredible breaking news former new
york governor andrew cuomo will be
charged and arrested as early as next
week
charged with sex crimes we are going to
talk about all of it there was some
confusion over the last hour as to
exactly what was going on um there was
an initial report and then there was a
report that the first report was
premature and then there was a third
report that the second report was wrong
about the first report and the first
report was exactly essentially correct
now we're going to go through all of it
but this doesn't look
particularly good for
a former new york governor andrew cuomo
who already had to resign in shame
and there was a question as to whether
he would evade or avoid
as the case may be
uh some kind of criminal charges and the
answer is no
so i know people are already talking
about a perp walk
listen
with someone like andrew cuomo
the expectation usually your lawyers
would negotiate that you go in you
schedule it
usually no handcuffs
you know maybe briefly very quickly mug
shot and then you're out so that that's
typically the way they do it with these
guys uh but that's more of a logistical
question and we won't necessarily know
the answer to that um until next week it
seems so we're going to momentarily get
into
the articles and what we know so far
this is breaking news and um the the
you know we're learning about it as we
go here just a couple programming notes
again as a reminder
um monday november 1 that's this coming
monday
is the start of the kyle rittenhouse
murder trial
we are going to be covering it let me
see when when are we covering it live
um i don't know about the rest of the
week but monday we're going to kick off
our coverage at 12 45 pm eastern time 9
45 a.m pacific time if you want to watch
some of the kyle rittenhouse
um
trial
with us that is what we are going to be
doing there
and um
i don't know what else to say about it
but that's what we're going to do
elements of bathrooms
um i want to say thank you to jen here
for gifting two twitch subs also thanks
to deeper shades of house
lars now subscribed for 18 months in a
row that's an accomplishment in and of
itself
you can also sign up on my website and
we'll get to that a little bit later
okay let's get right into it let's get
right into what we know so this is the
this is the sequence of what took place
today the first article i saw was from
the new york post which should always
make us say are we sure about this sir
and
you know we'll get to that in a moment
uh new york post reporting andrew cuomo
to be charged over alleged gropping oh
groping of former aid according to a
source
disgraced ex this is fox news right i
mean you know new york post fox news
disgraced ex-governor andrew cuomo
is expected to be arrested next week
and charged with a misdemeanor in the
alleged groping of a former aide
the anticipated charge is the result of
a probe by albany county district
attorney david source
a spokesman for the state office of
court administration confirmed that the
misdemeanor complaint against cuomo has
been filed in albany city court
as this is a sex crime a redacted
complaint will be available shortly
cuomo has been charged with forcible
touching
according to the independent new york
focus website which cited information
from an unidentified court clerk this is
a picture a visual element of
ex-governor andrew cuomo with a dunkin
coffee
if convicted of forcible touching cuomo
would have to register as a sex offender
and a judge would decide on his likely
risk of committing another sex crime
if he were deemed to pose a moderate or
high risk to the community his
photograph name address and other
information would be posted online sores
opened a criminal investigation of
63-year-old cuomo on august 3 shortly
after state attorney general leticia
james detailed the alleged groping
incident in a report
that accused the then governor of
sexually harassing 11 women
trump puts this guy to shame but 11's
still bad
including nine current or former state
workers here he is with a woman
um that's brittany camiso
alleges cuomo put his hand up my blouse
and cupped my breast over my bra
yikes
yikes
six days later brittany camiso an
administrative assistant went public in
a tearful interview on cbs this morning
the governor needs to be held
accountable what he did to me was a
crime he broke the law
here is the document let's see if we can
get
um a little more
okay
the people of the state of new york
versus andrew cuomo
i amy kowalski the complainant herein am
a police officer
i accuse andrew cuomo the defendant
on this action in charge that on
december 7 2020 between the hours of 3
51 o'clock in the afternoon and 407 0
clock in the afternoon at 138 eagle
street on the second floor in albany
county of albany state of new york
united states
uh northern hemisphere earth
solar our uh
solar system yes the defendant andrew
cuomo did knowingly and intentionally
commit the class a misdemeanor of
forcible touching in violation of
section 130.52 subdivision 1 of the
penal law of the state of new york
a person is guilty of forcible touching
one such person intentionally and for no
legitimate purpose there are legitimate
purposes for cupping a breast this was
not that no legitimate purpose forcibly
touches the sexual or other intimate
parts of another person for the purpose
of degrading or abusing such person or
for the purpose of gratifying the
actor's sexual desire
to wit at the after set date time and
location the defendant andrew cuomo did
intentionally
and for no legitimate purpose forcibly
placed his hand under the blouse shirt
of the victim redacted
and onto her intimate body part
specifically the victims now you do need
an apostrophe there the victim's left
breast for the purposes of degrading and
gratifying his sexual desires all
contrary to the provisions of the
statute in such case made and provided
the above allegations of fact are made
by the complainant herein of my own
knowledge gained through the course of
investigation
the attached new york state police
blackberry pin messages cell phone
records testimony etc
sworn before me etc etc investigator
okay good so this is the complaint now
shortly after this article in the new
york post was published
this article came out
okay
saying that this was an era
as
i say error but you know i was
channeling bernie that this was
erroneously issued so then i was saying
wait a second
am i streaming or not
what's happening here
criminal summons erroneously issued
against former governor andrew cuomo
this is another picture of andrew cuomo
a summons charging cuomo with
misdemeanor forcible touching was
prematurely issued
okay
um no final decision had been made by
the sheriff's department or the albany
county district attorney about whether
to file charges the summons has not been
served
so
when this was published it said this is
not necessarily happening this entire
stream was at risk of being erroneous
the summons was issued without the
consent of the alleged victim
etc etc it it turns out this was wrong
and indeed
andrew cuomo charged with misdemeanor
sex crime for alleged mansion grope
let's listen to the coverage here
reporter jonathan deinst following this
from our newsroom john
as a forcible touching complaint has
been filed in albany city court against
former governor cuomo the complaint and
an apparent restaurant has been issued
by the albany county sheriff's office
the complaint alleges governor cuomo
forcibly touched a female victim the
victim's name we are told will be
redacted
portions of that filing
public this afternoon out of albany the
albany county sheriff's office is not
commenting the albany da's office
only its separate investigation is
ongoing at this time
numerous victims have claimed then
governor cuomo improperly touched them
or harassed them while in office
brittany commisso is one former staffer
who made a complaint a female state
trooper also among numerous women who
complained about the governor's behavior
the complaint again not publicly stating
who the victim is related to today's
misdemeanor complaint
no comment from a spokesman yet for
governor cuomo but it appears the
sheriff's office has moved forward with
a criminal charge against the former
governor it is a misdemeanor count
according to a spokesman for the court
administration but as of now again no
comment from the sheriff's office or the
albany county da's office those offices
are separate and it's our understanding
the sheriff can move forward with a
charge without involving the albany d.a
governor cuomo's lawyer has said in the
past his reputation was destroyed by the
investigation conducted by the attorney
general's office calling the press
conference unprecedented yeah so i see
people in the chat making good points
which is aside from this
it's crazy that given this that trump
has evaded i mean what is it 46
different women have made some sort of
allegation against donald trump um it's
it's crazy it it definitely is crazy um
but it is happening um former new york
governor andrew cuomo charged with a
misdemeanor sex crime for allegedly
groping a woman at the state's executive
mansion now it's already a misdemeanor
is uh is is andrew cuomo gonna do prison
time no
no
um but this this is gonna be not not so
good for him so we're continuing to
watch and learn about all of it in the
meantime
um
newsmax just running agit trash we're
gonna get back that they had a um
they had us as this was breaking they
had a story about
like dogs and costumes it was kind of
interesting so we're gonna keep an eye
on this expecting a press conference uh
potentially soon um so we're gonna watch
this as we go through a few other
different things today but andrew cuomo
charged and presumably next week will
surrender there is unlikely to be any
kind of particularly salacious or
titillating perp walk
um
but that is uh that is that is the
latest on andrew cuomo which is wild
i want to say a big thank you
to gildor 2k
leedy lobotomy as well as msu pyromaniac
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 4 5 and 6. also want to remind
you we do have a very special coupon
code 69 off on my website for uh the
coupon code elements of bathrooms
elements of bathrooms you can sign up at
joinpackman.com
i will thank you the first person to use
the code today it counts as five so
where ordinarily we would go from six to
seven
the first person to use the code today
we would go from six to seventy two no
i'm sorry sorry i was five
six to eleven from six to eleven
um so that's just a little little added
incentive okay a couple other things to
go through i do wanna read a few super
chats before we get too uh distance from
that
penny lefkowitz says cuomo is mad that
his italian heritage won't protect him
anymore
also it's become pretty clear that male
entitlement is off the charts among the
elite a lot of different assertions
there for sure
philip says why is the southern district
taking forever to bring charges against
the trump organization is it because of
the scope of the case
i wish i could say
but
same question applies to matt gates not
southern district but same question
applies to gates
same question applies to
a number of other people
pepe says never to minimize sexual
assault but do you think this was a
setup many wanted cuomo gun to protect
trump from state charges i you know i
want to be really careful about that do
setups exist sure
do i have any evidence this was a setup
no
i have no evidence this was a setup and
so i want to be really careful
mike says didn't they say just last week
that the new york attorney general's
report was biased will that make the
report inadmissible i don't know that
they're relying on the report for this
for this criminal charge
cigar or sager says sir would it be wise
to hold off from visiting the usa until
2023 planned in 22 but scenes of
passengers throwing tantrums on flights
changed my mind i've gotten this
question a lot from people that's really
up to you
it's really up to you
um i'm gonna be flying a few times uh
next month or i guess december so i
guess technically the month after next
um i don't know what to expect i've
flown uh how many flights have i been on
during the pandemic i guess one two
three four five six seven eight i guess
eight flights
other than some american anti-masters
who were just doing like the mask was
down here or they were like holding a
drink the whole flight to justify in
their mind not wearing a mask at all
there was no like big commotion
um that i experienced so you know that's
just my anecdotal
anecdotal thing
okay
um let's see a few other things i wanted
to go over
oh i got another update from a people
about the ice cream
this was a viewer who took a picture of
the graders section at their grocery
store and a few interesting things here
first of all very strongly stocked with
black cherry chocolate chip which is
really the the flavor that's at issue
here and the one that's causing so much
controversy
and 549 a pint as i told you guys you
know when i was when we were on the
website for graders and it was like 12
bucks 12.50 a pint and i said this is
not what they're charging at the grocery
store people didn't believe it but it is
see 549 sometimes i get it for 4.99 what
i genuinely don't understand is why they
sell on their website for 12.50
something that at the grocery store
is 549. i don't understand that as a
business model usually it's like
it's skip the middleman to get it for
less
skip the middleman to get it for more is
kind of uh kind of weird you know
okay so we got that also a very very
good wanted poster posted to the
subreddit
um david pakman has been involved in the
distribution of highly illegal
membership discounts in several cases
globally against international law
um
yeah so this is a good one
i would check out the uh
check out the subreddit
if you're interested in more
uh elements like this
elements of bathrooms right
so that's a good one i like that
um
okay
hold on and i've got so many other
things as we wait for more news
oh hold on i'm being told to check
newsmax
yeah it's like every story on newsmax is
just like is this really a story let's
just listen to like a minute
and others the opportunity at the lowest
incomes but the biden administration the
pelosi leadership in the house is the
opposite in fact john boehner the former
speaker set up a scholarship program
using dc tax dollars to benefit the
poorest kids here in the district of
columbia what did pelosi do zero it out
don't you imagine expectations and the
terrible performance of our public
school system we must give the poorest
and the neediest families a choice for a
great education because that unlocks
major major story over there on uh on on
newsmax they're really all over it uh so
we'll get we'll get back to that um in a
bit actually i think there was let me
just see if i can find it here there was
another thing on the andrew cuomo stuff
that i wanted to pull up for us
where is this
uh
i apologize that it's taking me a moment
is this it
nope this is not it
okay we may have to get back oh wait oh
hold on here it is
nope this is not it either okay
nope yep don't have it all right good
all right so we're standing by there may
be a press conference related to this
andrew cuomo thing and we're going to
watch it if that does take place i want
to say a huge thank you to hal doll
holly who just signed up with the coupon
code elements of bathrooms elements of
bathroom as promised the first person to
use the code counts as 5 which puts us
at 11. also huge thank you to kenneth
griffin who just signed up on my website
using the coupon code elements of
bathrooms and derrick villa who also
signed up on my website
using the exact same coupon code very
much appreciate that in all seriousness
in all uh in complete and total
seriousness all right let me go to
another article related to the andrew
cuomo thing this is this is breaking
news right now
um so we are continuing to learn
about what how it's going to go we have
some news now about the arrest let me
pull up the arrest news
just have all my different things here
new york times
here it is update from the new york
times
oh no
now we've got a whole login thing with
the new york times let's see if we can
get it taken care of
okay here we go
nope not gonna work
all right well that's too bad
ah here we go okay good
all right new york times now reporting
on the
um charges against andrew cuomo let's
look sexual misconduct complaint is
filed against andrew cuomo mr cuomo
former governor of new york resigned in
august after a state attorney general
report concluded he sexually harassed
multiple women that's a picture of
andrew cuomo
a criminal complaint accusing governor
andrew cuomo of forcible touching filed
in albany city court
a misdemeanor complaint was filed in
albany city court against the former
governor this afternoon said spokesman
lucian
chalfen the complaint came more than two
months after brittany comisso a former
aide to cuomo filed a criminal complaint
against them with the albany county
sheriff's office she accused him of
groping her breast while they were alone
in his residence late last year
the complaint signed by an investigator
says cuomo intentionally and for no
legitimate purpose forcibly placed his
hand under the blouse shirt of the
victim and onto her intimate body part
as we already read from the complaint
it's said that cuomo touched the
victim's left breast for the purposes of
degrading and gratifying his sexual
desires all contrary to provisions of
the statute
the complaint says it took place on
december 7th we knew that
ah here we go there was confusion on
thursday afternoon surrounding the
complaint i already apprised you as to
this the times union of albany reported
the complaint was filed erroneously
the report said neither the sheriff's
office nor the da's office had yet
decided whether to file charges a
spokeswoman for the sheriff's office
would not confirm that the complaint was
filed erroneously or answer questions
um
and then
lawyer and spokesman for cuomo didn't
respond
well so it seems here that they've not
real they're not the new york times
seems to be careful they're not actually
saying
the report of it being erroneous is
erroneous right i mean they're not
they're not actually saying that which
is interesting
um
it all sounds pretty bad yeah
not gonna lie about that
um
so we're going to keep uh
keep an eye on that and expecting live
coverage
here to continue so wait a second we've
got that's nbc
and this is abc
nbc and abc
there's pbs
okay i think we've mostly got the
various feeds
it is shocking that they got cuomo
before gates i know no i know i know
exactly what you're saying
i want to say thanks to daniel monsoor
who just signed up on my website using
the coupon code elements of bathrooms
elements of bathrooms number 14 today
really appreciate that i mean i really
really do appreciate that also thank you
to darkar druid
who says obama obama
and working joe both of whom signed up
with twitch prime
really appreciate that really really
appreciate that very much will i take
calls today
oh i don't know listen i don't have a
ton of time for the stream today so
let's let's make a deal okay
instead of our normal hundred members
and twitch subscribers if we just get to
50 i'll open phone lines for a bit okay
so we're only 34 from that
and i think that that's eminently
reasonable i'll open phone lines at 50
if we get there in the meantime i did
want to get caught up on a few
voicemails as we stand by for the
possible uh press conference related to
andrew cuomo let's listen
hey david trump on the
1917-1918 flu and his uh burnt stakes
with ketchup
i think that um
i i'm probably on the wrong side of this
argument that trump's not a narcissism
because he
clearly is but i think that if he
realized he was wrong he would just do
one of his lines where he says you know
some people say 1917 some say 1918
yeah and uh just play it off like that
yeah that may be that maybe
um i want to say thank you to nug
wrangler for gifting five subs on twitch
putting us at 21 getting us close to
halfway we have a reduced goal in fact
let's just make it 50 i can actually
change it to 50. look at that um so
phones phones may open today
whitney continues to call in
so um i came from the east coast and i
ended up on the west coast
and i just feel like i got wrapped up in
like a lot of stuff that's like
not exactly like applicable to
no that'll happen that'll happen to the
best of us
hi mr pakman um i'm calling a reference
to
uh chronic pain patients this is
something that's never talked about
because we're not supposed to exist
the unbelievable
amount of time that is spent on
every other netflix tv show that goes
down and
drops it and it talks about this
the opioid crisis and everything
but the one thing that nobody ever talks
about or rarely ever talks about are the
current pain patients
that are getting dumped on or they're
dying because we can't get our
medication yeah that's definitely an
issue that's an issue
but i'm continuing about my message
about um shapiro's book
um honestly all right we're not really
worried too much about ben shapiro's
book hi david my name is janice um
i'm watching the uh the deadline for
coming up with an infrastructure package
before
election day and um i'm wondering
why
uh the democrats don't find a purple
state that is willing to work with them
and the hell with mansion
the
so there's 50 democrats including
mansion
if you say the hell with mansion
are you saying maybe find some
republicans is that the idea i'm not
sure the numbers don't work i i like the
idea i mean you're thinking but i i the
numbers the numbers simply don't work
um i want to say thank you to jay
tandoway for gifting five subscriptions
on twitch putting us at 26 phones open
today at 50 very special exclusive
stream a phones open at 50 and you can
use the coupon code elements of
bathrooms for 69 off my website that'll
also get us
really close to the number that we need
a whitney continues to call in
so i like noticed this really amazing
thing in society where people like
started like promoting stuff
like products and stuff like that yep no
that's for sure
do you actually wrote the discourse
wait what was what was that
do you actually wrote the discourse
do i actually
roll the discord
what is that
do you actually wrote the discourse
do you actually rode the discord
man i don't know what that means did i
wrote the discord
do i run it
yeah
okay
so i was like kind of um looking into
like defining gender roles because just
like lately
i don't know just throughout my life
i've felt like really
like just treated like i'm somebody else
like um a lot of times people will kind
of like talk to
like
something else
in the room when they're talking to me
something else like to a plant they
would speak to
david you took a call yesterday from a
guy
talking about maybe you're doing a
future segment
about uh conservatism in the uh hispanic
community yeah and you said it was an
interesting topic that you you just
didn't have the enough bandwidth for
right now
i demand an apology uh
i'm just waiting for you today for you
to say
uh oh we will have to double click on
that please don't do that corbin jargon
why
i didn't think bandwidth was corporate
corporate jargon
i really feel like fathers here in
america can sometimes like give their
give their daughters like mixed messages
as far as like um
who they are or their aim in life
yeah i've read about that
hello david my name is mike
from daytona beach florida thank you
i've been watching the show for about
two years love the show daily watcher
i had a quick question
in regards to
one one-term presidents uh it seems
what i've noticed is a lot of people
get very involved in politics around
elections
and
it seems with
people and
how we have more access to
media and news
and even with the pandemic people have
more time on their hands to really get
involved and to do more research yep no
that's a very interesting point
hi david this is lacey i'm a long time
um watcher and listener
i had a question about all of these
audits
considering none of them have turned up
any results and yet they're still
following through
and now they're even trying to do one in
texas
could it be
a possibility that they're not after a
win by recounting the votes but their
goal is in fact to just
replace voting machines
i don't think so no i think that they
may have other goals like just making
any election results not trustworthy in
the eyes of voters or
you know whatever but no i don't think
it's i don't think it's focused around
voting machines
um i don't
hello david sir i'm calling my wife is
up in here tucker carlson and sean
hannity
come up with this misleading
presentations of their statistics and
so-called facts
do they get help with this is there
somebody supervising them or do they
have a staff of people that helped
concoct this yeah they had they all have
staff they they do you know i don't know
exactly who
runs each element of it
but um
yeah
hi david so i'm watching today's show
and i got through the segment of the
colon powell death and it's sad that we
still even have to be
reminding people that the vaccine is
still effective even though it's not 100
effective like it's pathetic that we
still have to keep repeating this but
now you're on to the segment about
tucker carlson and i'm not quite done
with it yet but i just wanted to vent
that
i can't stand his [ __ ] face and every
time i see it with a stupid expression i
just want to like punch my
tablet screen but
anyway
just wanted to
say that yeah no that's a reasonable
reaction actually it's a very very
it's a it's it's a common reaction to
seeing tucker carlson's face
hi david love the show i was listening
to the podcast today and it said
something about 40 percent of
marylanders uh currently dying from
clovid are vaccinated that is a false
number it is actually eight point three
six percent um i was watching the clip
from let's let's listen to the the
coverage on newsmax of this attorney
cuomo was forced to resign over multiple
sexual misconduct claims earlier this
year and other issues like the china
virus issue meantime los angeles and
long beach ports will find shipping
companies over the ongoing backlog
issues officials say the fines will
begin on november 1st and they will
cover containers scheduled to be moved
by trucks or trains containers that will
be moving okay well so a brief mention a
brief mention of the of the situation i
guess
um all right
hey david um
i i want to hear more of uh
just these crazy i don't want to call
people crazy i'm sorry but people who
call into your your voicemail line uh
sometimes you skip through them very
fast
and uh
i know most of these people most people
don't have any good points they make
just you know saying weird stuff but
i i feel like you cut it off kind of
quick and i would like to sometimes hear
from your regular uh
callers you know people who call in
constantly i'd like to hear a bit more
of
um you know their messages that they
send you because sometimes you you cut
it off kind of all right i mean if you
really want that i'll i'll subject you
to it i don't know that you're really
gonna like it um here's an ex let's
let's do it let's do it okay
but i really feel like people who like
just are like really expressive
um i feel like they get like
broke into like
some sort of weird like anti-gender
and
i just feel like
people's genders shouldn't
discriminate like based on like how much
money they make like as a gender
because i think that sometimes like
people's personalities or like
perspective on life isn't like
you know necessarily aimed at
making like life easier for people
you know some people just don't make
life easy and
it's not bad it's just they're really
expressive people
and
i don't necessarily think there's
anything wrong with it or that people
should like root them in or name call
them or say like they have like mental
illnesses unless they're like committing
crimes and you can't like get it through
their head and like rehabilitate them
rehabilitate a criminal
uh based on like a certain algorithm
then i think that's relevant but just
like in society if someone's like
extremely expressive and thinks
differently than you and says different
things and
looks at the world more creatively than
you do
i don't think that it necessarily means
that they should be like medicated and
taken out of society and
manipulated and all this other weird
stuff that people do
people who
otherwise wouldn't be that [ __ ]
relevant in the first place they just
express themselves and it's like okay
you know why do you have to make
everybody relevant in order to
get human rights i just don't understand
okay
so
that's when i don't cut the voicemail
early
okay that's just
that's that's what it is
um
if you're saying well that's
kind of deceptive because that's a
particularly weaponized caller um okay i
mean let's let's try a different one
here's a different one i'll we'll play
the whole thing i don't know if i'm
going to be able to but i'll try
hi david my name is michael calling from
sacramento and a comment about colin
powell's recent death and everybody you
know making a a big hubbub about the
fact that he was actually inspired his
car
um but i feel like this is a missed
opportunity to
point out why it's important that even
if you don't feel
you are at risk
that yes breakthrough cases do happen
yes people who get vaccinated die and
they are less likely but it's gonna
happen sometimes so you are indeed
putting at risk people who have taken
all the precautions that they possibly
can
but due to circumstances you know that
are at least partially outside of their
control or completely outside of their
control
they
are unfortunately more susceptible and
still
could die or suffer a very serious
illness
anyway just a thought
thanks bye
it continues two more minutes
interestingly
we're doing okay he's actually a little
sick at the moment
all right looks like they just forgot to
hang up so i won't i won't keep going
because there could be
there could be private stuff in there
hey david this is evan from colorado i
was just wondering if you had thought
about
um having any anti-vaxxers
call in a
sort of
debate with you i guess sort of
go through the socratic method with them
and try and
um
maybe
get
some people to who are open-minded to
maybe change their mind i don't know
yeah i mean if if someone wants to call
in i guess you know i'm i'm i'll talk to
whoever you know
uh people asking about about what's
going on with live calls so
i cut the goal
from 100 to 50.
i cut it in half just so we could try to
get some calls i've done my piece
um
twitch subs count
and website memberships count if you
want to do website we've got a 69 off
coupon code elements of bathrooms
okay
or you could do twitch you could do
either the website's the most efficient
i'm i'm coming halfway okay and i'll
we'll i'll open discord calls um until i
have to run if uh if if necessary but
there's a lot going on here also people
continuing to ask now about now it's the
mustache i got rid of the goatee now
it's a mustache yeah i'm just bored i'm
just trying different things
but i think it's i don't think it's bad
and i took someone's advice of in the
neck area shaving this way rather than
down i didn't realize i had been shaving
against the grain basically my entire
life
um much more much more uh successful
much more successful so yeah we're gonna
try we'll see what it looks like by
monday and um
yep we'll keep an eye on it not much
else not much else to say about it at
this point in time but it's definitely
the type of thing that is just for the
just for comedy just for boredom that's
all it is it's no
no big deal all right let's let's listen
to a few more voicemails then we'll see
if we get some phone calls here
so i was looking at some judeo-christian
values
and there's a lot of questions that i
had and i wasn't sure if you were the
person to ask them or like if it should
be like an open discussion because it
seemed like you were for like majority
matters kind of a thing
and sometimes it's like the majority
doesn't talk right
that's an issue chakuseki everybody's
favorite radiologist showing up with a
super chat and says david do you accept
shiba inu coin for memberships also
what's your halloween costume this year
i have no halloween costume
i'm we're not currently accepting shiba
inu coin for membership but i do own
some
um i've got i mean it's it sounds like a
lot but it's so cheap i i've gotten the
millions of coins but it's like these
are fractions of a fraction of a penny
um
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna ride it either
to somewhere good or down to zero
that's where i'm at right now i want to
say thank you to bully whiff the great
for subscribing via twitch alta
dangerous for subscribing via twitch our
rhino for subscribing via twitch putting
us at 29
and then bully with the great donating
10 subscriptions putting us at 39.
folks we might be close to opening phone
lines because we've cut the goal to 50
and
you can sign up on my website with the
code elements of bathrooms and we could
be opening phone lines before you know
it
which would really be
something
um
philip says drown me in a sink or shower
hold on
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times elements of bathrooms looking at
that very strongly
one of the wettest we've ever seen from
the standpoint of water exactly
exactly
thanks to mueller probe for gifting one
subscription putting us at 40
jen here has gifted another two putting
us at 42
and then two paper dolls gaming has
subscribed putting us at 43.
over on the website joshua frederick has
signed up using the coupon code elements
of bathrooms elements of bathrooms that
puts us at 44.
unfiltered has just resubscribed and put
us at 45.
whoa just a little extra there
uh
and then
bully with the great gifting another
five
putting us at 50.
ladies and gentlemen
we got him let's take some calls i have
a little bit of time before i've got to
go
[Music]
where did that come from we are going to
open up the discord davidpakman.com
discord get yourselves into the waiting
lobby that's the place to go if you
would like to chat with me
by all means
uh we will we let's now reset the goal
to a hundred i mean even though we've
we've done it
we will still try to keep going
um
let's see
um in the waiting lobby
let's get some people on let's go first
to nug wrangler it's been a while nugg
thank you
can you hear me
yes i can
okay um
so yeah i'm currently i'm in the
progressive should tank the bill camp
you know let's not forget that the deal
months ago was to pass the
infrastructure and spending bill at the
same time
uh but at the same time if progressives
don't
you know
uh take this bill to send a message i'm
not gonna you know call them [ __ ]
sellouts or or anything you know
yeah it's just the political situation
in this country is just so ah
i have a segment coming out a little bit
later today where i say i am like the
biggest incrementalist in the world and
i am pretty sure that progressives
should tank the bill at this point
because it doesn't have anything left in
it
yeah i i i just finished uh watching
that segment
since i'm a member of course of course
yeah for non-members you're going to
have to wait a little bit for that but
nug was able to check that out because
uh he actually has like i think three or
four memberships
uh yeah and um
you know one family member so we're kind
of hogging a bunch of memberships yeah
there may be none left actually because
you're taking them all but yeah no i
think um i i am i am as close as i've
ever been to say screw it say absolutely
not because otherwise who wins right if
you pass some trash bill with like a
slush fund in it for some infrastructure
and nothing else
the centrist democrats win
and the republicans win and so it's like
what what are we really doing here
yeah we would just be demoralizing
you know the a bunch of democratic uh
voters because
it just tells them what are we going to
get done anyways i wanted to
get that in and um if i'm if i may be so
bold
um kind of bring up and what happened if
you watched the election way back
because i'm a member from way back yep i
remember when there was a donation drive
to hire a progressive engagement
coordinator
dip the audience's toes into activism
yep and i just wonder if you have a
maybe thinking about that again
i'm not right now we're we're pretty
fully staffed right now with a lot of
different things going on that was like
from an old old old
iteration our total staffing level is
much higher than it was at that point
and things have just kind of shifted
around but i i never closed the door
permanently on any idea
but it's not high on the list right now
because we've got so much else going on
and gearing up for 2022 and different
elements
okay thanks for the call and uh green
apples are cringe
sorry what was that
green apples are cringe that's that's
like an aggressive move
let's go next to um
let's go to bob from colorado
hello yes you're on the air bob yes um
oh well i actually got on i didn't think
i was going to get on okay i didn't
either to be honest
okay so here's my question i know almost
nothing about economics sure it's not a
topic i find particularly fascinating
love it i'm not particularly good at it
so you know we see a lot of um talk
about the inflation
lately and supply chains and all that
how much of that actually has to do with
biden and america and how much is just
the global situation and how worried
should we be very little has to do with
biden i mean listen remember back in
2020 when people were going crazy
getting toilet paper and pasta
and canned beans and all these different
things
we weren't saying it's trump's fault
because trump's president his
mishandling of the virus was his fault
but not the supply chain stuff and it's
similarly not biden's fault right now
now with inflation it inflation may be a
real thing that's happening it may not
be transitory we just don't know yet
it's also not joe biden's fault
we have sort of global circumstances
that that affect so much of what's going
on here a little bit of inflation is
good if you believe in the sort of
standard economic context which not
everybody does i've explained that
before but uh no these things are not
the
it's i mean listen if you think it's joe
biden's fault you should have to explain
why
well i don't but you know i just don't
know enough about economics to say
either way right fair fair fair point
well you're investigating which is an
important thing
all right thank you for answering my
question david
thank you so much somebody did find the
original source of the obama clip
[Music]
okay
i wish we had more context if somebody
can find more context with it i would
appreciate that it seems to lack context
but um
that's okay
let's go next to bitdefender from cancun
mexico
um
so
you long time no see um
i had a bit of a question
i know you're not specialized in
migration or anything similar you're
you're
specialized in economics and business i
if i recall correctly right
yes
you're familiar with the concept of
revolving door migration
regarding mexico and the us yes yes
so
i i was having some discussions with
some professors uh specialized in this
field
and some are arguing that while
it would have
and there was some discussion in the
discord while it was the best policy at
the time
uh and you know inevitably it got
removed or reduced to nothing with
current immigration policy in mexico
um some are some argue that
returning to it might not be the best or
or even doable
uh in today's
day and age
even if
you know
economic analysis would say that it
would be the best way forward
um i don't know if you have an opinion
on this
uh you know as an alternative to the
obama trump biden
policy on the border well i
first of all something very strange is
going on with your audio i'm not sure i
understand your question revolving door
migration refers to the idea of people
who come for example to the u.s
but with the eventual goal of going back
to their home country either for
economic reasons or social reasons or
whatever the case may be
what exactly is the question you're
asking so
yes so
more more specifically a phenomenon that
happens
tied to this
is people live in mexico and work in the
u.s right
um
so and and that can't happen right now
at least not in the most part no not how
it used to happen
uh because you know whenever
migration you know the border got
strengthened people
had to choose where to live
and a lot of people chose the united
states so you know whenever people
actually make it to the states they try
everything they can to actually stay
there
contrary to you know what
republicans might
favor which is keeping mexicans in
mexico right
yeah
um with ironically with a softer border
now given the northern triangle
migration that may not be possible now
you know because
given you in addition to mexican
migration you have
uh
migration from all over south america
you can't have a porous border as you
used to have with
you know when it was mostly mexican
migration uh coming and going
bit you know i love you but i have no
idea what your question is
no
my question is if you have a if you have
an opinion on this like because
all we've seen from uh you know
democratic policy on this is nothing
uh and this is the only thing i would
think of that would make sense in a
democrats mind to you know for policy
changing the border you know because we
can complain about how it's terrible
what they're doing
what they've been doing
are you saying that democrats should
propose encouraging revolving door
migration what are you what is that i
don't know i just i'm not understanding
you know it's just an idea
but you know what what are what's the
proposal from democrats right now
well i think democrats are prioritizing
fixing daca
uh and doing something permanent there
and it just seems like what you're
bringing up is um
not high on the list of priorities and i
have to say understandably
understandably because there's there's
lower hanging fruit i think to deal with
right now um
uh wouldn't and wouldn't fixing daca be
like a band-aid
rather than addressing the problem from
the get-go well you fixing daca if
you're permanently fixing daca it
wouldn't be a band-aid for that element
of course yeah
right
bit i love uh love the questions i'm
gonna let you go it's getting a little
confusing and noisy there but continued
good luck in cancun it sounds like
everything is happening there let's go
next to i hope oh hold on i need to
thank someone first i want to say thank
you to kiko70
as well as chief boris for signing up
via twitch and related
twitch mechanisms also uh oh that's it
actually that's too bad all right let's
go next to alozec from england you were
on the air
alozec from england you were on the air
oh hello hello
hi
hello
hi i'm looking at
oh yeah my question is
how dangerous do you think the next
election will be uh considering how
um
controversial things have gotten
since lost the last time do you mean the
midterms of 22 or the next presidential
election uh presidential or like oh
what's your opinion on how by um how
dangerous do you think it would be i
think it's too soon to know it's too
soon to know if trumpists get crushed in
22 and trump fades away and trumpists
are demoralized that's one end of the
spectrum if trumpists all win in 22
trump runs i think it's potentially
extraordinarily dangerous very very
dangerous
hmm
okay is that there's just a quick
question just mind your thoughts on that
thank you all right thank you that's
alozec from england let's go next to our
friend kyoko from japan we haven't heard
from kyoko for a little bit kyoko what
is it seven a.m on friday there
yes uh it's like seven seven a.m wow i
can hear you beautifully
okay great okay so um yeah thank you
again for taking up my call pleasure um
it's really honored to talk to you again
so um i'll this time i have a question
i'd love to hear your opinion um you
know so many of us uh concerned about
anti-vaxxers you know vaccine skeptical
and how difficult to reach out to them
right and then i think many uh vaccine
hesitancy uh comes from the you know
fundamental distrust of the government
and big farmers
because you know pharmaceutical
companies are profit-oriented
organizations and all companies are and
there is nothing wrong with it but um
they are so often put profit over
people's safety and health and the
people don't maybe believe the
government is capable of preventing
those companies from hurting us for
their profit so um you know we saw time
and time again that they betrayed us so
unfortunately maybe uh even the people
who believe in science we just don't
believe the data published by the pharma
companies or the government institutions
you know thinking that they may not show
the data which is conveniently
inconvenient
for them you're not wrong i mean these
are the roots you're completely right in
that historically anti-vaccine sentiment
in the u.s comes from one of two places
distrust of big pharma or distrust of
the government uh and to some degree
those
um hesitations are logical but that you
can't just be you have to find a way to
be satisfied if someone gives you the
information where they say hey that's
okay interesting here's how the vaccines
work here's the truth about the studies
here at some point you have to say okay
you know what
these are profit driven companies you
can't always trust governments but
clearly the right thing to do is to go
and get the vaccine so you're not wrong
in identifying the elements that cause
it i think you're right there
right and i just really uh you know
personally you know i just was uh very
happy to go and get
myself vaccinated and i thought i mean
in japan as you can see now that most
people are very happy to get vaccinated
the number is going up growing
but you know it what do you think how
can we reach out to those people i mean
it's just i know it's difficult
educating them how randomized you know
double blind placebo controlled studies
yeah it's hard to convince people with
that no i know what seems to be most
effective is that if they hear from
people that they already trust that it
makes sense to go and get the vaccine
that seems to be the most effective
kyoko oh i see yes that makes sense yes
okay great that's that's all from kyoko
i have a question i have a question for
you i want you to be really honest with
me
oh sure the famous stinky tofu is it
really that stinky is it really that
stinky
oh wow that's such a specific thing i
mean are you really are you talking
about the type of tofu from okinawa who
is a ferment which is fermented and it's
really really stinky i am indeed i am
exactly talking about that wow uh if you
like cheese and you like blue cheese i
know you're against blue cheese i'm sure
you love it
oh my god no blue cheese is not good
so yeah it tastes like cheese i mean
smells like cheese but i mean i have to
say annatto who is a fermented soy bean
that's stinkier but i like i've had that
i've had that before and i kind of like
it
yeah yeah yeah okay so then i'll go for
the stinky tofu then i'm sure you
just one last question kiyoko before i
let you go because i'm working on
improving my miso soup technique are you
in favor of or against
the dried fish flakes to make the dashi
broth
oh i'm totally um for it you are
yes i mean but it's a really um um you
know the trick is i mean you mix
with the vegan and non-vegetable
ingredient
ingredients together yes you know the
more
elements in the broth is better
that's what i think yeah i am 100
for the fish flake i went and i got the
uh the bonito flakes and there's what's
what's the other kind that you can use
also
uh the the dried sardine if you can get
them ah no the dried sardine yeah i mean
yeah it's just a dried sardine it's just
a whole fish so you may get offended by
the queen at the moment no no i won't
get a friend listen i think we have made
major progress in bridging the cultural
gap of the united states and japan here
we are all in favor of the dried fish
flake oh wow really that's so exciting
maybe i can eat good miso soup in the
united states then
i think you could i think you could
kyoko always a pleasure thank you for
the call okay thank you so much for
taking my call again thank you bye take
care bye-bye
wow guys that's a top five caller of all
time there's just no question whatsoever
and i also was just given a video this
is where the obama thing came from
i'm told it's at the 43-minute mark
let's check it out here
o'rourke voted against the border wall
oh that's a good thing to him he voted
against kate's law and he voted for
obama
oh that is the best
amnesty
amnesty obama
it's actually even better in context
that can someone clip the full thing
that's amazing
that is something else i'm gonna just do
one more here
and
if ted doesn't win your second amendment
is gonna be in trouble big trouble
remember that
o'rourke voted against the border wall
oh that's a good thing
he voted against kate's law and he voted
for
obama
amnesty
amnesty obama
man
that is really something
that is really something trump is
visiting virginia today is he doing a
rally
trump virginia october 28th is he
visiting or doing a rally
um
trump says he will visit arlington
chanting
i'm not actually seeing that he's going
to be there
no he's going to do a monday teller
rally i might try to cover that all
right everybody uh i appreciate
everybody being here with us glad we
were able to take calls and do all these
different things i gotta run i've got a
commitment
that i need to attend to so thank you we
will back be back very very soon